empty of patients for more than six
months
london's huge nightingale hospital is
preparing for reactivation
a contingency emergency planners have
requested
as the capital's hospital trust struggle
with a huge surge in covert patients
nhs staff we've spoken to say the
situation in many hospitals
particularly around london and the south
is increasingly desperate
with exhausted doctors and nurses
inundated with more covered patients now
than at the peak of the first wave
what's happening in our critical care
unit now
is that the demand for those beds is
outstripping the
the supply of medical staff so it means
that where normally we would have one
itu nurse for one patient often at the
moment we've now got one eye to you for
two
three patients and and that ratio seems
to be
um getting larger um i mean i've got 38
years
in the nhs i've got 21 years in critical
care i've never seen anything like this
and and it looks like it's shaping up to
be much harder than the first wave
only two nightingale facilities this one
in exeter and another in belfast are
currently still treating covet patients
any move to fully reactivate the others
raises obvious questions over staffing
how we're going to manage to open
nightingale hospitals with our existing
staffing
it is a really serious question and one
that really
needs to be answered by the government
how exactly are we going to staff these
these nightingale hospitals our staff
just now completely exhausted
they are there and i i can't
overestimate that enough they are
absolutely on their knees now even more
alarmingly
health professionals say the peak of
infection
hasn't even hit yet with a father
sergeant cases
expected from those groups who've mixed
over christmas
and they're appealing to the public not
to break the rules
this new year's eve mark white sky news